It's time we look at some of the key functions
that the widget system exposes out to developers.
Understanding these functions will set us up
with a good knowledge base for us to build UI elements.
On the left, we've got screenshots
of the blueprint versions of some of these key functions
whilst on the right, we've got screenshots
of the code functions that we'd find inside user widget.
Firstly, we've got construct,
and this will be called when the UI has been added
to the viewport.
And we can think of this as our begin play function
that we'd usually see when working
with actors and components.
From there, we've got tick
and this behaves exactly as you'd expect.
This function will be called regularly and consistently
with each frame being the default.
Finally, we've got destruct,
and this will be called when the UI is removed
from the viewport or the parent.
We can think of this as our end play function
that we'd usually see
when working with actors or components.
Moving on, we've got preconstruct.
This function will be called
as our widget is created the same as construct.
However, the function will be called
in both the game and editor.
The purpose of this function is purely
for cosmetic updates that use locally owned data,
so you can't safely access the game at this point.
Lastly, we've got mouse button down and mouse button up.
These functions are called from the widget system
to notify that the mouse button has been pressed
or released within the bounds of this widget.
And we typically use these functions
to drive drag and drop functionality.